United States will be revoking the
effect of America's signature from this
badly misguided treatment we're taking
our signature back the United Nations
will soon receive a formal notice that
America is rejecting this treaty
as part of this decision I will sign
right now in front of a lot of witnesses
it's a lot of witnesses a message asking
the Senate to discontinue the treaty
ratification process and to return the
now rejected treaty right back to me in
the Oval Office where I will dispose of
it
by taking these actions we are
reaffirming that American liberty is
sacred and that American citizens live
by American laws not the laws of foreign
countries thank you
[Applause]
you